lutter contre l'exploitation des enfants
à travers le monde c'est le thème d'une
conférence internationale qui vient de
s'ouvrir aujourd'hui à oslo gouvernement
mais aussi ong syndicats patronat
cherche les moyens d'y mettre fin
commentaire de joël hasard ils
travaillent comme des grands dans une
mine de charbon avec la fierté de faire
vivre une famille entière les ignorent
la peur et le danger en main d'oeuvre
jetables pratiquement gratuit les
enfants de la misère sont une proie
idéale pour les négriers des temps
modernes sous-développement surnatalité
sont la toile de fond de ces violations
humaines sociales livrés à eux mêmes
pire vendus par les leurs ils subissent
par millions jusqu'à l'horreur de la loi
du marché comme en thaïlande et aux
philippines où des proxénètes exploitent
leur innocence
trois millions et demi de petits
brésiliens entre 10 et 14 ans c'est plus
chaque jour autour des fours à charbon
de bois
et pourtant la 12e puissances mondiales
interdit le travail des enfants ce qui
doit disparaître
mais alors disparaît tout de suite c'est
toutes les formes de travail qui les
mettent en danger que ce soit danger
physique d'ange et psychique que ce soit
la prostitution les travaux qui les font
mourir à 20 ans moi j'ai vu certains de
tes enfants dans l'espérance de vie
n'est de que de 20 ans cccc infernal 120
millions d'enfants de 5 à 14 ans
travaillent à plein temps comment
éradiquer ce fléau des pays pauvres
l'unicef propose de traiter directement
avec les entreprises qui les exploitent
aux termes de ces accords ont dit on va
scolariser les enfants dans l'ic dans
leur usine dans l'atelier claira on va
leur donner le même salaire même s'ils
sont scolarisés pendant trois heures et
puis petit à petit on va remonter l'âge
auquel on recrute les enfants il faudra
du temps pour sortir les enfants des
circuits de production les sous
traitants du tiers-monde n'offrent t-il
pas les meilleurs prix sur le marché
mondial